my revenge is not towards one person
it's more for everyone who was so cruel
to me and really shunned me well that
might be different now because it
appears Chloe is firing shots at her
most recent act and Ichi is breaking it
all down on Tuesday the 34 year old
reality star cut cryptic on her IG
stories posting a message that reads
quote you will always find love dreaming
if you date people you have to raise now
there's no specific mention of Tristan
Thompson but Chloe has kind of become
the queen of posting cryptic quotes ever
since their split earlier this year amid
reports that the 28 year old allegedly
cheated on her with Kylie Jenner's
bestie
Jordan would do you feel as though you
are the reason why Tristan and Chloe are
not together I know I'm not the reason
that Tristan and Chloe are not together
I know I'm not the reason over the
weekend Chloe posted more thoughts on
love writing being in love in this
generation is terrifying
loyalty is so rare and people are so
quick to choose a good time over a good
thing and she followed up later on
stating oh you're a narcissist well I'm
going to introduce you to an empath to
Humble you so you'll know what it's like
to value respect and love someone other
than yourself oh I do want to ask about
this character that you had a baby with
oh man yeah Oh earlier this month
Chloe told Jimmy Kimmel it was probably
time to stop dating basketball players
should have listened to me I'm sure my
grandmother I should probably start to
date like the Countians or something
well we don't know when Chloe will be
open to love again we do know she's
thinking a lot about it between her
social posts and this news she's getting
a new love beam TV show kind of the
youngest Kardashian is set to
co-executive produced a new
investigation Discovery Channel show
called twisted love it's a spin-off of
her previous show Twisted Sisters
family turn on each other to this extent
and it's about what happens when love
and affection turn into extreme
obsession and jealousy which leaves us
wondering if Khloe's cryptic posts could
somehow be related to the show in a
press release announcing the new series
which is set to premiere in 2020 Chloe
said she's excited adding quote
relationships can be complicated and
these never-before-seen stories show
just how dangerous it can be when love
turns lethal